[Musique]
le plus important en ce moment
c'est que tu dises la vérité
un rapport a été déposé on connaît toute l'
histoire
je voulais me sentir libre je voulais faire
ce que je voulais pour la première fois de ma
vie
[Musique] c'est
ton élève  c'est comme un
abus de pouvoir monumental,
tout le monde panique à propos de cet homme,
la police est venue chez moi aujourd'hui,
qu'est-ce qui se passe avec toi, Eric
a déjà été
inapproprié avec toi, Miss Wilson, je t'aime, je t'aime,
ils ont émis un mandat d'arrêt contre toi.  repose-toi, je
ne peux pas manger, je ne peux pas
dormir, je ne peux pas avancer dans
ma vie
[Musique]
je dois vivre avec ça pour toujours, alors fais-le
toi